hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that was played in the 14th
interpolis Tournament of 1980 I was
played in Tilbury Netherlands and it's a
game between Uh current world champion
at that time Anatoly karpov versus
former world champion Boris past him it
was quite the game and a lot of you have
been asking me in the comments what is
happening with karpov as there were well
there's just a new headline every day
that karpov is in a coma there are some
conflicting uh information uh uh
regarding uh all of this uh I've read
that his daughter Sophia said that he's
recovering in a hospital that he's in an
induced coma then there are some other
uh
uh well the source is saying that his
wife Natalia is saying that he's
actually at home recovering
um there's just not a lot to be found on
the subject so you know the world's a
big place if you have any uh Insight on
this do share uh like I said supposedly
he's uh in in hospital in Moscow uh just
recovering from uh trauma caused by a
head injury now if I know more I will
inform you guys uh but I didn't just
want to share the news I also thought
it'd be nice to show a nice game by the
by the former world champion so let's
dive straight into it uh faces are very
very interesting player Boris uh
borisposky and the karpov opens with
Ponte E4 we have C5 spotsky goes for the
Sicilian Defense Knight to F3 with D6
and D4 so the open Sicilian nothing out
of the ordinary here captures captures
Knight F6 Knights the C3 and now E6 this
evening variation uh where Bishop to E2
is by far the most popular move nowadays
but karpov goes for Pawn to G4 this is
the Keras attack and it is well even the
today is the second most popular
continuation you want to advance the
pawn to G5 so sparsky stops this and
pawn to H4 yeah you really want to push
that pawn to G5 Knight the C6 now
putting pressure on the D4 Knight and
Rook to G1 uh we have Pawn to D5 uh best
way to counter a flank attack is the is
the counter attack in the center we
often say and now you could capture but
Harper goes Bishop to B5 so you can see
that he's very very rapidly developing
his pieces now interestingly uh both
karpov and uh well and spaski and tal
amongst others played in this tournament
but it's like carp of play like tall in
this tournament and Tall plate like
Harpoon in this tournament um
uh you'll you'll see what I mean by this
uh so Bishop B5 we have Bishop to D7 by
sponsky E Captain D5 Knight captures and
now Knight captures on D5 e captures on
D5 and now Bishop to E3 so just nicely
developing pieces and notice the H4 Pawn
is always hanging but it's just never a
good time to capture it here if you go
for Queen captures on H4 uh you've uh
grabbed the pawn but you allow for some
very nice development Queen to D3 and
now white will Castle Queen side and you
don't really want to do something like
this so instead Bishop to E3 with Bishop
D7 nasposky will capture the pawn with
with the bishop and karpov just plays
Queen to D2 saying okay you are welcome
to capture on H4 now the real question
is what should spassky do here does he
Castle does he captured does he play A6
does he does he capture the the Knight
maybe on D4 uh what's uh what happens
after castles is actually extremely
interesting here you would see something
like Knight captures in C6 Bishop
captures Bishop captures Pawn characters
and now a queen side castles from
carpool so this does leave his Queen
side a bit vulnerable but even after
eliminating one of the attacking pawns
you will still face G5 so that's kind of
the issue you can defend this but you
have to calculate everything super
precisely so if H captures the bishop
captures Bishop captures who wrote
captures uh now you can play Rook to G1
you can shift your Rooks to the H file
but let's say queen F6 and now if Rook
to G1 G6 and now if F4 with the idea of
F5 you will play Rook d8 and if F5 then
you're gonna play Rook to E5 this is how
you defend the disposition
uh not uh not very comfortable but you
you can play it uh sposky decides that
he doesn't want to Castle just yet he's
gonna grab the H4 Pawn First which is uh
at least an odd decision since you would
capture it eventually even uh in that
line that we've shown but okay carp of
castles Queen side and now comes the
bishop to F6 you don't have time for
something like Queen E7 and castles
because just Bishop captures and now
nothing is good if you play B captures
then you're no longer Castle in Queens
and then display Bishop captures then
you lose control over the F5 Square the
queen hangs the bishop is attacked the
the G7 Pawn is attacked here you just
resign
uh but after Queen side castles we have
Bishop to F6 by sparsky and now it is uh
as of this moment in move 14 uh that we
have a completely new game or this
position has never been reached again uh
we have castles here uh oh no we don't
have castles castles is one thing you
could do uh but uh sorry not castles um
Knights the F5 preventing castles uh the
problem is if you Castle now then uh
carpool would very happily eliminate
your H6 spawn with check g-captress and
G5 just completely blast open the
position if Bishop B5 you can even play
Queen characters on D5 and now you have
to worry about too many things for
example if Bishop E6 offering a queen
trade Queen E4 attacks the black queen
and if Queen A5 attacks the bishop
attacks the A2 punches Bishop D3
threatening Checkmate and there's just
no good way to get to get out of this
mess so instead after Knight F5 spaska
says alright Bishop captures on F5 I
have to do this G captures and now again
castles is met with H6 because now
karpov has the semi-open G file so A6
and now karpov plays The Very
instructive Bishop captress on C6 uh B
captures and not Bishop to C5 which is
just awesome if you think about it
because the bishop here was really
putting a lot of pressure on Black's
King side but the bishop on C5 is
putting even more pressure on on the
black king
now you have to think about what happens
if Rook the E1 check lands so spaski
plays Rook the B8 he shows that he's not
worried about Rook D1 King to D7 is a
perfectly fine Square for the black king
for example rookie one checking D7 and
there's no good way to continue this
attack this Pawn on F5 is even
preventing you from further attacking
the black king so karpov does uh well
what karpov does best he just finds a
move that completely eliminates any and
all Contra play for black and that's
usually uh well in any position that
will be the move and that is Pawn to B4
Now The Rook is no longer powerful on
the B file as the bishop and Rook were
putting pressure on that V2 Pawn the
bishop no longer serves all that much
purpose and well you're still cutting
off the king from uh from escaping to
the king side so this bishop is
definitely carp of strongest piece for
the moment and here [ __ ] should just
continue with his plan King 37 probably
spaska was waiting for Rook D1 check
before he plays think the D7 sort of
stepping out of check with tempo but
King 37 is what you should play here and
now after you uh let's say C4 try to
open up the position King C7 but I mean
that's quite quite a maneuver King the
D7 to C7 not not many people would play
this uh probably who would play this one
black is Anatoly karpov himself he would
find this but posky played Rook the B5
and this just allows carp of to blast
through the position with Rook Gita E1
check King to D7 and now we said that
the king and D7 is perfectly fine so
what's the problem now the problem is as
possibly put a rook on B5 and he put it
there for a good reason he want to play
a queen to B8 put even more pressure on
the B file play A5 open up the position
but now Pawn to C4 comes with Tempo and
now the Rook is also hanging so you
don't have time to just play King to C7
and probably not probably definitely
spaskis all of this and he decided to
sacrifice the exchange for the attack
Rook captures on c5b captures and now
look at this bishop to G5 sort of wins
karpov's Queen but not really Pawn to F4
and now Queen to F6 is going for Queen
to A1 check and what do you make of this
position uh it's carp of the move you
have only one move that wins the game
for you feel free to pause the video and
try to find it the only winning move for
karpov while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on not touching that
bishop and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is C captures
and D5 this is the only move that wins
the game but uh just for fun I will show
you what happens if you capture the
bishop it's actually a really really
complicated line uh that goes with Queen
to A1 check King C2 Queen captures and
C2 now if you go to D3 Queen captures on
C4 will be deadly so you have to go back
and now Queen A1 check queen king to C2
Queen to a for checking to C1 and not
Rook the B8 uh will be very very hard to
Parry for white you are up a pawn but
still not much you can do here Queen to
C2 for example will be met with Queen A3
check King to D2 now you will win the
White Queen and after you let's see
captures on D5 uh you will force a trade
on B2 now of course the Blackwing cannot
capture the black the White Queen is
pinned so Queen captures on B2 Queen
captures King to E3 and now let's say
queen C3 with check goes after the pawn
here taking F2 Queen captures with check
King to G2 and RC captures on D5 leaves
black with a past tape on past the D
Pawn for probably a past H Pawn at some
point
so uh if anyone would be playing this
for the win it would be spaski so
instead carpool plays C captures on D5
this is the only winning move and now he
has to survive the attack Queen the A1
checked King C2 Queen captures an 80
with check King to D3 and now any
further checks will just be blocked with
the White Queen Queen B5 check Queen C4
and there are no more checks so uh
spaski decides to trade Queens here
Queen captures on D2 Rook captures and
the bishop captures on F4 we have Rook
to A2 and now uh finally when the dust
settles C characters on The 500 captures
on A6 spaska has done the exchange but
he's up to pawns so can he make
something of the position well uh
there's one way to try and that is to
start pushing the past age Pawn so H5
came to D4 we have H far H4 and King
captures on D5 and unfortunately for
bodies uh he cannot Advance the pawn to
H3 because he gets checkmated just C6
check King C7 rookie seven check and
after the d8 you will play real captures
on F7 now with ideas of rooked A8 check
followed by Rook captures on V8 once the
bishop blocks and after King the C8
still just Rooks the uruki check
rubbishop to B8 and C7 and that's it for
black
so after this King captures on D5 move
uh Rook the B8 was played by spaski and
now comes Pawn to F6 spectacular
finisher by karpov completely opening it
up at the position threatening the
capture Creator pass Pawn Rook day E7 is
a threat and of course if G captures
what was played in the game Rook
captures an F6 Bishop to G3 and now Rook
captures an F7 with check King to d8 and
now just Rook the f8 with check and it
was in this position and move 35 that
Boris paski resigned the game as there
is nothing more to be done here uh
problem is that if you go to C7 then you
just get checkmated Rook to E7 is
Checkmate the pawn covers the B6 square
and if you don't if you go to let's say
D7 then just Rook to F7 check King 38
and rookie 4 with some Rook to G4 Rook
to G8 action and you check made the
black king all over again spaski is just
not in time to advance this Pawn uh two
more squares If he if the position was
different if he could grab a few more
Tempe if the spawn ended up on H2 then
of course carpool would have to worry
about the pawn a lot more but this way
karpov was just too fast and wins the
game very nicely so a very very
complicated position and here uh car uh
spaski complicated as much as possible
with this bishop to G5 check F4 and
queen to F6 move but carpal finally
found the only uh winning move in the
position and that's all there is that's
the story of this game but yeah again
when you think about it what really won
the game for karpov was Pawn to B4
because this just gives sparsky no more
moves none of spassky's moves do do
stuff and unless he finds King D7 King
to C7 right away he will not have a a
great time
uh so yeah very nicely played by carp of
karpov also the one first place in Seoul
lead uh so uh proving that he is
definitely the the the reigning world
champion as this is a game between the
former and reigning world champion and
like I said uh karpov had the most wins
in the tournament so it's like he played
against Stalin top played like uh like
carpool because out of 11 games style
Drew like nine games to 1-1 and lost one
uh so yeah very nice performance a very
nice game by karpov and if I hear any
more news regarding Harpo I will inform
you guys but if you if you have any
insight on this doucher in the comment
section so thank you all I will see you
soon and have an uh excellent rest of
your day I would like to thank Marcus
grabble James Chambers Bradley Peterson
Robert of sepion and Bowman equity for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and uh well I
already said it but yeah I will see you
soon uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions
um you know and whatever else happens in
the Chess World and of course continuing
preparing The steinit Saga for your
viewing pleasure see you soon guys